- [Steve] All right.
- [John] All right. Hey
everyone, I'm John Huehn.
I'm the chief of Launchpad for Pegasystems
and with me today is Steve Bixby,
who is our Senior Vice President
of Product Engineering.
And we are delighted to be spending
the next 20 minutes with you
building an enterprise-grade
agentic SaaS application
that can run a complex
and regulated process,
and be sold to thousands of B2B clients
in just five easy steps.
And those steps include making the design
with agentic powered blueprint,
making it real here on AWS,
making it work with
enterprise capabilities,
making it available to your subscribers
and making it rain with
real live customer usage.
So we're going to
demonstrate how a FinTech
that we're going to call "Homeland"
can build and sell to banks
an agentic application
that will dramatically
accelerate processing
and deliver a great customer experience
for a scenario that many of us
may have gone through ourselves
or may one day go through in our lives,
which is mortgage pre-approvals.
And of course, banks
are like super excited
to see their work get automated,
but they also can't afford
to have AI introduce variability
into important decisions
like credit worthiness.
And that's where a lot of
agentic applications struggle,
they have armies of agents
trying to manage other armies of agents
to deliver an outcome, and of course,
that just naturally breeds
all kinds of variability
which can't exist in financial decisions.
So today we're going to use workflows
to manage our AI agents
to deliver a controlled,
deterministic, predictable outcome.
The kind of outcomes that
regulated industries,
like banking, actually love.
And to build our application,
we're going to use Launchpad,
the AI-powered low-code app
development platform from Pega.
And if you've never used Launchpad before,
what you should know is
whether you're looking to
build a new application
or enhance maybe a legacy
application with workflow
or Gen AI into it, or
you're looking to replace
or re-platform a tech
debt laden old application
with something new and modern
that you can innovate on faster,
then Launchpad will
dramatically accelerate
your speed to market, reduce
your development time,
and reduce your costs with a
vibe development experience
that helps get your app
started, with a managed database
and secure scalable cloud powered by AWS
with industry leading workflow integration
and UX and reporting capabilities,
and with prebuilt subscriber management,
administration and configurability,
all with a usage based pricing model
that scales with your business.
So ultimately, Launchpad gives
you everything that you need
to build and sell an
enterprise-grade SaaS application
without the cost and complexity
of managing your cloud,
your security, and of course, code.
So we're gonna get started,
here's our scenario.
Homeland, our make-believe FinTech
that builds and sells apps to banks
has identified a gap in the
mortgage pre-approvals process
that impacts people like Sarah.
Sarah's Dream House
just came on the market
and she is super excited.
She very quickly booked
a showing of the house,
contacted her bank,
provided all of her documentation
to get a mortgage pre-approval
and the corresponding letter.
But unfortunately, her bank took two days
to process her application and
get back to her that letter.
And sadly, during that time,
somebody else bought Sarah's dream house.
Imagine how disappointing
and Homeland understands that pain.
So they're going to build
an agentic SaaS application
for banks to reduce the processing time
from days to seconds and
deliver a great experience
for folks like Sarah,
something that actually looks like this.
An AgTech SaaS application with
a conversational interface.
So Steve, I'm hoping
I can count on you now
to play the role of Homeland
and I wanna build an app
that manages the mortgage
pre-approvals process
and other loan origination stuff.
- All right, well that's a
challenge, we're gonna do it,
well, hopefully the wifi holds up.
We're gonna build this real
quick, last session of the day,
thank you all for being here.
Okay, John, could you actually
just maybe say that one more time?
- Okay Steve, I want to build an app
that manages the mortgage
pre-approvals process
and other loan origination stuff.
- We got it, all right,
brilliant, that's enough.
That's enough to get
started with this process,
so here we go.
We're in Launchpad.
If you want to see Launchpad,
you wanna try it yourself,
we're at the Pega booth just over there.
Everything I'm showing here
you can do for yourself,
check it out at Launchpad.io.
All right, so it said perfect,
what's your application name?
All right, so-
- [John] That's gonna be "Homeland."
- [Steve] This is "Homeland."
- [John] Yeah.
- [Steve] So "Homeland,"
and, all right, here we go.
I can now build your loan
origination application,
which will include a mortgage
pre-approval process,
it's identified the industry,
the location, et cetera,
all the things that are needed
to build an application.
Obviously we haven't really
provided enough context,
but it's giving us the
option to start building.
So for the sake of time,
let's just go for it.
- [John] Let's build.
- [Steve] All right, so,
it now it says, "I'm
building your, I'm starting
"with an industry template
and customizing the workflows,
"connecting the channels,
setting up the personas
"and configuring the
data and integrations."
Boom, all right, awesome.
So the chat is now
pushed over to the right
and we're presented with the
sort of development environment
for Launchpad here.
And you can see that
our Launchpad readiness
is sort of like a quarter of the way done.
We can keep an eye on that
as we walk through the process here.
So it's identified that we
are this Homeland corporation,
we're in the US, retail banking,
and this is a loan origination
application, great.
And if I click here in the
middle of this diagram,
this is gonna show us the
workflows that it created.
So it created eight workflows
it looks like, here they are,
and mortgage pre-approval
is in fact one of them.
- [John] That's good, the rest
of them are the other stuff.
- [Steve] That's right, lots
of other stuff, that's good,
that's what we asked for.
Let's take a look at the
mortgage pre-approval process.
All right, so what Launchpad does for you
is it takes that business process,
breaks it into a series
of stages and steps
to organize the business process.
I can now interact with
this, add steps, add stages,
drag them, drop them, move
them around and update this.
But if we look at it,
it looks like we've got
a collect application data,
verifying information,
and then we go through
financial assessment,
pre-approval decision and
then ultimately finalization.
So this, this actually looks pretty good
in terms of delivering
what Sarah's looking for
in that scenario you described.
So, let's make a few changes to it,
actually before we do that,
let me show you the data model over here.
So it's also generated
a data model for us.
This thing's generated a
full UI, it's all there,
we're gonna see it in a minute.
Again, I can update this,
make changes to it as needed.
You see we've got an
applicant name, date of birth,
W2, annual income, all the
things that we would need
for that mortgage pre-approval process,
all created with generative AI
using the bedrock models from AWS.
So let's go back to the lifecycle now,
let's make a change, John,
what should we change?
- [John] So I think, Steve,
maybe we wanna get some human eyeballs,
If somebody's gonna
ask for a pre-approval,
maybe over $5 million.
- [Steve] $5 million.
- [John] It might be good to have somebody
actually take a look at that.
- [Steve] All right, so in the
pre-approval decision here,
so I could just vibe this
over on the chat on the right,
but I wanna show you a cool feature here
where I can actually do it in line
where I can just click
on the area of the screen
that I want to make the change to,
and I can say, "configure
the system so that
"any loan request over 5 million
requires human approval."
Period, boom.
- [John] Nice.
- [Steve] So, awesome.
So this just inserted
this human approval step
where it's a decision actually
to determine if we need
a human approval step.
And if you wanna know
what did this actually do
behind the scenes,
I can open the left-hand panel here
and it's gonna show all of the assets
that have been created that
support this application.
And here's that human approval
down here at the bottom.
It's a decisioning rule, it's private
and it kind of has it has
it generated an expression
for loan amount greater than $5 million.
- [John] That's good.
- [Steve] So that's awesome.
All right, let's, let me see,
let me just close this just to show
you can work with the full screen here.
Let's make one more change,
Let's add a like a, gentix step
or at least a placeholder
where we can insert one.
So let me see, let's
integrate the AWS Nova agent
to automate the verification
of the employment
through the approved third party service.
So you can add decision steps,
you can add human steps,
which would require like a screen
or some sort of interaction,
whether it's through self-service
or maybe through a contact
center, agentic conversation.
You can add agent calls, you
can add decisions, automations,
all of that here to build
out this application.
Now because we have such a
short window, we're gonna say,
all right, this is probably
what we need from here.
Let's preview it.
Let's see what does this
application look like
to a potential end user?
All right, so here we go.
This is a, it even says right here,
"Preview, demo bank." It's not real.
- [John] That is not real, this is demo.
- [Steve] This is how you
test the application now.
And I'm presented with this
virtual assistant that says,
"Hi, I'm your virtual assistant,
how can I help you today?"
I'm gonna tell it,
"Hi, I'd like to get
pre-approved for a home loan."
It says, "Sure, I'd be happy to help.
"To get started, could you please provide
"your full name and date of birth?"
Of course, my actual name, Steven Bixby,
June 14th, 1983, not my actual birthday.
- [John] I was gonna say I did not realize
how much younger you are than me, Steve.
- [Steve] "Thank you, what loan amount
"would you like to be pre-approved for?"
I'm looking for $1 million.
(Steve laughs)
Got it, to proceed, so do you
understand what this is doing?
It's actually going through
the first step of the process
and trying to collect the
information that's necessary.
To visualize that further,
in this preview portal here we can say
okay, that's what it's gonna look like
through this self-service chat,
but what would it look like,
like in the bank back office
in the desktop application.
So this is the application
that it's created for us
and you can see there's a
dashboard, there's chat,
there's all kinds of stuff
that's going on here.
And I can actually create
any one of these workflows
right from here, or
instance of the workflow,
including that mortgage pre-approval.
And now I'm gonna see those
fields that were prompted
in that first step of the first stage,
which included the applicant
name, the date of birth, email,
phone, annual income, and the W2 file.
- [John] So that's pretty cool
because you just built
the core logic of the app
and we're showing it in the
conversational interface.
But you can actually do the same thing
on the employee desktop
and it also would work on
your website for self service.
- [Steve] Mobile app.
- [John] Mobile app, you know,
build that logic in the core
in the center one time and it deploys
across all of your channels.
- [Steve] Exactly.
All right, so let's assume
that this app is perfect,
there's all kinds of things
that we probably would want to go tweak
to make this our own,
make it actually serve
the purpose that we need.
But from here, I think we
can, let's launch this thing.
So what's unique about Launchpad
is that it's built
specifically for organizations
that are building products, SaaS products,
that they are going to then go sell.
So we're, this is, we're a provider here
and we're gonna go sell
this to our subscribers.
So when you launch it,
it's actually gonna take this
blueprint of our application
and make it real.
So it's doing the domain
data modeling, the workflow,
the UI screen generation,
the integration setup,
the security configuration, all of that
to make sure that we have an
app that we can actually deploy
so that our subscribers could use it.
So I'm presented now with
my list of subscribers,
like Homeland subscribers,
there's five banks here.
I'm just gonna say let's deploy it
so that all of them have access to it
and let's deploy this application.
All right, so now that I've done that,
made this available to all my subscribers,
I'm looking at my subscribers dashboard.
So as a provider, I can
now see what's happening
with other apps that I've built
and that have been deployed.
I can see the usage, I
can see even revenue,
things like that.
And right here I'm seeing those banks
and seeing that the Homeland subscription
is active for all of them.
So now that we've built this application,
I'm gonna do a little bit of fantasy here.
We're going to flip to one
of these bank's websites
and assume that they've already deployed
this virtual assistant on their website.
So it's no longer the, you
know, "This is not real" bank,
it's actually the UBank
or U Plus Bank website.
So here we are on their website,
they've deployed this assistant
here and I can click on it
and it says, "I'm your U
Plus Bank virtual assistant.
"How can I help you today?"
So very similar to what
we saw in the preview
in the development environment,
we're now seeing live
for a real subscriber
and this time I'm going
to say I'm Sarah, right?
So let's be Sarah in this use case.
And "Hi, I'd like to get
pre-approved for a home loan."
All right, "Sure, happy to help.
"To get started please
provide your full name."
So this is gonna take us
through that same process.
Again, I'm gonna say I'm Sarah this time.
Sarah Wilson, March 18th, 1974.
"Thank you, what loan amount
"would you like to be approved for?"
Let's do a million dollars again.
- [John] All right, everybody,
a million dollars for Steve,
a million dollars for Sarah,
everybody a million dollars today.
- [Steve] And now it's asking for the W2,
same as we saw before, let's
actually do that this time.
Let's upload the W2,
submit that,
"W2 was received securely
"I'm now evaluating your finances
"to determine pre-approval amount.
"I'll have the decision for you shortly."
Here we go, fingers crossed,
let's hope Sarah gets approved.
It's not over $5 million
so that rule's not gonna
be in play that we added.
Boom, "Congratulations, awesome,
you've been pre-approved.
"Would you like me to email?"
Yes, definitely.
"Check your inbox.
"Is there anything else
we can help you with?"
Let's say, "That was it.
"Thanks for getting back to me so fast."
Awesome.
All right, John, so I think I did it.
I built the application, I
think Sarah's gonna be happy.
So, let's flip back.
- That is awesome.
Thanks so much for
sharing all that with us.
So I'm just gonna quickly recap.
You know, going back to our five steps
with what Steve has shown us.
So the first thing, Steve, you did,
you made the design
leveraging vibe development,
to create your gen AI powered blueprint.
And then you made it
real, secure, scalable
on a pre-built and or ready
built AWS architecture.
You made it work with
enterprise-grade capabilities
and with workflows
managing your AI agents.
And you made it available
to your subscribers,
like U Plus Bank,
to configure and deploy
to their customers.
And you made it rain
with real life customer
usage from folks like Sarah
who are using the U Plus
Bank deployment of the app.
So in five simple steps, you
built an enterprise-grade,
agentic SaaS application
that dramatically
shortened processing time
and delivered a great
experience for Sarah.
And you took, you know, a
cumbersome bank workflow
and you enabled, you
know, that to be automated
to deliver an experience for Sarah
whose story can now finally
have a happy ending.
So there's really not much more
for Steve and I to share,
except to say if you have any questions
about anything that we have shared today,
or if you wanna learn a little bit
about the amazing companies
that are already building
agentic SaaS applications
like Steve just showed on Launchpad.
Or if you wanna learn about
our security capabilities
and how our full technical
review can accelerate your path
for building an application
and getting it onto the AWS marketplace,
we would love to see
you at the Pega booth,
which is number 366 just over here.
Or if you'd like to get
started with Launchpad today,
just go and start, you know,
get started on your own for free.
You can just click that get
started button and start
with easy step number
one, designing your app
with your JNAI-powered blueprint.
So with that, we will say
thank you all very much
for spending this time with us today,
and we hope you enjoy
the rest of your time
here at AWS Reinvent.
(audience applauding)